we also have um an amazing woman named
mary
who's here who actually has a question
about
dating let's uh roll the tape please
hi drew hi dr phil my name is mary paris
i'm 31 years old and i live in brooklyn
new york
i keep dating these guys who seem
wonderful at first and then they become
these awful human beings who are
narcissists and cheaters
i somehow am missing all the red flags
so what can i do
to attract a good guy
i mean that is a fantastic question mary
and you happen to have the man on the
mountain himself dr
phil dr phil take it away
well um i should recuse myself because i
haven't been
on a date with anyone but robin for
almost
50 years it's been a while
but i sure talked to a lot of people
that are in this dating scene
and look there are all kinds of
personalities out there
and first off you got to keep your
standards really high and you sure don't
want to chase the wrong one
because the right one won't run that's
for sure
and if you've got somebody that
shows you early on and trust me
they will show you early on who they are
and don't ignore that no matter what
they tell you they will
show you who they are and when they show
you that they're narcissistic
self-absorbed it's all about them
and they're unreliable unfaithful or
whatever
trust me cut bait and the only thing
worse than being in a bad relationship
for a month
is being in a bad relationship for one
month and one day
first off have in mind what you're
looking for
do they need to be gracious do they need
to be
sensitive do they need to be
polite do they need to be
employed and you also need to have a
list
of criteria that are
eject button if you hit it no matter how
charming they are
no matter how how they present
themselves
if there are things that you know are
discontinuation criteria if those things
are there
hit the eject button and get out and
this stuff about oh i'm attracted to bad
boys or whatever
that's that's a bunch of bull decide
what you want
and do not compromise going in
trust me that person is out there you
want mr wright
not mr right now mary do you think
that you can take this advice and apply
it
oh definitely i think i find myself
constantly as dr phil said
lowering my standards just to keep
someone with me
so i'm definitely definitely taking that
advice i'm no more compromising at all
another thing i think us girls do
i don't know if this is your
circumstance but i used to hear
from guys like yeah i'm just not like
into being
serious right now and in my head i was
like oh
well you don't know me yet exactly
exactly
then i was surprised when they weren't
serious months later
and i'm like oh you he told you
but you can't you would be the one to
change all that
listen to what they say they're actually
usually telling you the truth
pretty clear up front and we as women
start to
think i can change
if you're telling yourself you're going
to fix them or change them
no you don't want to do that there's
something called instinctual drift
you can pull them out here but they're
coming back
to where they started you don't want you
want somebody that has
core values aligned with yours in the
beginning and if not
you need to look for someone else
they're out there i promise you
and mary i can tell from talking to you
looking at you
listening to you you don't have to
compromise
thank you for the practical thank you
thank you mary
thank you